So in the previous quiz we have seen that we can fetch these instructions then
we rename them to eliminate false dependencies. So let's see whether we have any
false dependencies after renaming and what does that do to our IPC or
instructions per cycle which is the opposite of CPI. Well here we have a true
dependence. And that true dependence is still there in our renamed program.
Similarly here we have a true dependence and it is still there in our renamed
program. And then here we have another one, and it is still there.
However here we also have an output dependence from R2 here to R2 here and
then another one to here. And
we have an anti-dependence here and one here. So if
we look at all of the dependencies then basically this is a sequential program.
So for our fetched program, we have the CPI of one which is also the IPC of one.
For our renamed program, however, this anti-dependence is no longer there,
this output-dependence is no longer there, there is no anti-dependence here and
there is no output dependence here. So really, here we can execute this,
this, and this instruction in the first cycle and this, this and
this instruction in the second cycle. So, for our rename program now,
we have, that we can execute, this, this, and this instruction. Three
instructions in the first cycle, these three can be done in the second cycle, so
overall we have six instructions over two cycles. The cycles per instruction
is two cycles for six instructions, giving us a much lower CPI,
it's only 0.33. Or we can write it as IPC of three,
meaning we execute three instructions per cycle. As you can see,
our renaming gave us a much better potential for executing this program quickly.